hi this morning i caught miss coffee
been
watching the pdf of this paper entitled
using
anti-patterns to avoid ml ops mistakes
miss coffee bean what were you thinking
i guess you read it because you have
little to
no idea about machine learning in the
real
world no wonder since you are in
academia where
all the work you do ends in a paper but
you know
there is life to machine learning
methods even after they have been
presented in a paper
life you would like to know more about
okay miss coffee beans since i do not
know what
else to do with you what about this i
found the data leakage anti-pattern to
be
the most interesting one but the
write-up was quite dense
since the paper is made for experts
let's make it accessible to anyone by
explaining this together
alright miss coffee bean this paper is
sharing lessons about
ml ops which is all about putting
machine learning models into production
but also about maintaining the whole
operation
however the lessons of this paper are
not about what to do
and good strategies and patterns but
more about
what not to do so about the
anti-patterns
or anti-patterns clearly the authors
summarize
their experience here which means that
the lessons are more tailored for the
financial sector
but don't worry though their
applicability is much
wider than this the paper guides us
through anti-patterns ranging from
technical errors to cases of missing
knowledge about the context in which
machine learning is deployed
data leakage is one of nine
anti-patterns in this paper
yeah each one with catchy names but
data leakage is the most interesting one
to me because
these days i have been interested in the
bigger
question of model generalization
since the train dev test split is one
very weak test for model generalization
data leakage is the one responsible for
not letting us perform
even this simple baseline for
generalization
data leakage is a violation of one of
the first axioms that we were taught in
every machine learning course
do not let samples from the test set
leak into your training set
and vice versa otherwise you will
overestimate your performance since your
model
is already familiar with the data you
are testing on
so how can this be an anti-pattern if
everybody knows about it
and it's quite easy to implement right
well no it's not that easy to ensure
total separation between train and test
data
the authors report four ways of
accidentally enabling data leakage
each one is sneakier than the other okay
great so we are ready to see the data
leakage
anti-patterns shoot the peekaboo
anti-pattern is specific to time series
data
it is described in this little cryptic
paragraph
now here is what miss coffee bean
understood from it let's suppose we have
a time series and for splitting the data
between train and test set
we could say we have all the data up to
a certain time point t
to be the training data and all the data
after
time point t to be test data the
splitting pattern could be also
more complicated but the principle of
the peekaboo anti-pattern works the same
the problem arises when time series data
sets have at least
two dates the date of the actual
timestamp of the data point
but also for example the date when the
data becomes available like
in job salary data which becomes
available in march but speaks about
february so about the last month
this time lag and the exact timing of
things might be unknown to the machine
learning engineer
and messing around timestamps can really
mess up the train test separation by
accidentally including data from the
train set
from the past into the test set from the
future
combine this with a feature that is
highly predictive of another feature
and we will have completely
overestimated our
abilities of predicting the future
through this lag
so what is the real lesson here apart
from train test separation
know the data you are trying to model
know
what every tiny feature means the next
data leakage anti-pattern called
temporal leakage is also related to time
series data
with an ideal test set we would estimate
the model's true performance
when deployed into the real world
ideally the test set would be
independent from the training set to
estimate how well the model performs in
unexpected situations but this paper
warns us that if we take a time series
data and sample train and test sets from
it
in a non-sequential manner then the two
are not independent anymore because we
have technically seen the future during
training already
so we have turned this into an easier
interpolation problem
what was previously an extrapolation
problem of predicting the future which
is harder
the next type of leakage is oversampling
he talks specifically about oversampling
techniques that are usually applied if
one class is very
underrepresented in the data strategies
like smoties
mode or similar methods basically
interpolate between the new
few existing points to create new points
so in a sense the data has been smeared
out to have a larger population in the
feature
space but you see the problem the new
interpolated points would be informed
about
all points from train and test alike
therefore if we split only after the
oversampling strategy
we would have contaminated the test set
with train set information
and also the other way around of course
so from anti-patterns 2 and 3 we can
remember
the order of the data pre-processing
steps and splitting
into training test splits matters
the last mentioned anti-pattern
responsible for data leakage is called
metrics from beyond and the miscopy
being this is very similar to the
oversampling strategy
this talks about other operations that
if performed
before train test splitting could smear
out information from one set to the
other
one example could be data normalization
by subtracting the mean and dividing by
the variance for example
if we do this for train and test
together the normalization operation
informs the future train set of the mean
and variance of the whole set including
the test set
and vice versa of course which data
leakage anti-pattern
is the one that you hate the most and if
you're honest
which one of these traps have you fallen
into at least
once so that you have learned the lesson
forever
what are other data leakage examples
that you would like to share with us
if you're interested in what you have
seen so far read the whole paper to find
out all
about other anti-anti-patterns until
miss coffee bean will see you again
repeat after her always separate your
train
and test data like your life depends on
it